♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec le confinement,
le télétravail aussi,
la ligne entre vie personnelle
et travail est de plplplplplus
floue.
Et avec l'adoption de cette loi
du droit à la déconnexion,
l'Ontario a voulu, en quelque
sorte, rétablir cet équilibre.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici, au nord detotototo,
cette compagnie familiale
construit notamment
des ascenseurs industriels.
Et parfois, les communications
se poursuivent au-delà
des heurtrtrtrtravail
pour les employés.
UCEL s'est dotée, l'hiver
dernier, d'une charte du droit
à la déconnexion. La compagnie
promet donc, m m m m mesure
du possible, de ne pas contacter
ses employés hors des heures
de bureau. Elle les encourage
du même coup à stopper
les communications pendant
êêêêême période de temps,
à moins d'une urgence.
♪ ♪ ♪
Avec cette politique, l'Ontario
veut faire d'une pierre deux
coups : offrir de meilleures
conditions aux travailleurs,
et aussi, en attirer plus
pour s'attaquer au problème
de la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre.
Pour le propriétaire de UCEL,
qui était en déplacement lors
de notre passage, ce ne sera
pas suffisant pour faire
venir un nombre important de
travailleurs en construction.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici, dans cette entreprise
de marketing numérique,
on espère que cette nouvelle
loi séduise des travailleurs
d'ailleurs qui pourront
télétravailler sans
nécessairement déménager
en Ontario.
Le concept de droit
à la déconnexion fait son chemin
depuis quelques années.
En 2017, la France est devenue
le premier pays à se doter
d'un droit à la déconnexion
dans son code du travail.
L'absence de sanctions
fait toutefois en sorte
que les résultats sont peu
tangibles pour le moment.
Le Portugal va plus loin
depuis l'année dernière :
il est désormais interdit
pour un patron de contacter
ses employés en-dehors
des heures de travail, faute
de quoi une amende de plus
de 13 000 $ canadiens peut
lui être imposée.
En Ontario, si la loi
du droit à la déconnexion est
provinciale, son contenu,
lui, est déterminé par chaque
entreprise, ce qui pourrait
faire en sorte que son
application soit très inégale
d'un endroit à l'autre.
- La loi, encore, est plus
floue.
- Christopher Achkar est
un avocat qui accompagne des
entreprises dans la rédaction
de leur politique sur le droit
à la déconnexion.
Des inspecteurs du ministère du
Travail auront la responsabilité
de s'assurer que tous les
employeurs concernés se soient
dotés d'une politique du droit
à la déconnexion.
Mais pour l'instant,
aucune sanction n'est prévue.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le droit à la déconnexion
pourrait s'étendre au reste
du pays, car un comité
consultatif se penche
sur la question à Ottawa.
En attendant, c'est en Ontario
que le concept sera testé
en premier.
(rires